although you should know something
[ __ ] what I did 50 pushups
without stopping in the sand on my
knuckles up and down yesterday two days
ago fifty bro at 52 did my age man
[ __ ] I wish I had somebody to
high-five but I don't feel like
high-five and anybody in this [ __ ]
room yeah yeah that's right
and Trigon challenged to a little
competition and I was like what friends
do you hang out with but you can't do 50
pushups in the sand about right to use
me okay dude don't challenge me how many
can you do what asthma whatever you can
do way more please don't do this
you say way more yeah I'm not doing it
now please don't do this it's not doing
it now but don't say way more say what
friends do you have though
what is everyone 18 it was me I bet you
can't chug this beer like me it was like
two old dudes me Mulliken and Herman and
we were just [ __ ] around who Malik
Malik my buddy Malik be who open for me
okay he's great but he's 27 and you know
Hermes [ __ ] 30 and Malik Malik just
he's a [ __ ] complete goofball
hilarious hilarious
yeah and impress the [ __ ] out of me with
his comedy this weekend and he he just
goes he's got a shirt off he just
started lifting cuz he's just boxes he's
all skinny you started lifting but he
puts on muscle superfast and he's like
look at my back man looks like authority
my back looks like authority laughing
you guys are on the floor about to go to
bed he goes I did some push-ups to go
what he just starts doing push no cuz
these girls yeah yes being a silly goose
and as you don't put so he's looking at
me he's looking at me cuz I'm going
you're not going all the way down he
does 50 and 52 or 53 and so I had been I
had to get on there if I could do it
myself
bro you're welcome right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]